el avance de las tropas son generadas en
esta región de hardcore en el noreste
del país aquí estamos a 16 km de la
frontera con rusia ha cambiado de cierta
manera el balance de fuerzas en la
guerra ucraniana en este momento muchas
de estas fuerzas han sido trasladadas a
la región del donbass donde se libra una
de las batallas más intensas sin embargo
la situación en estas poblaciones que
han sido liberadas tienen bastante
complicación si bien están en control de
las fuerzas y ucranianas aquí sigue
habiendo cruces de artillería se huye
nada se oyen ataques constantemente
bombardeados mucha de la población de la
poca población que se ha quedado vive
todavía en los sótanos y por ejemplo
esta mañana se veía un automóvil con la
letra z que intentaba entrar a esta
población al final fue bombardeada no se
sabe si con un misil o con qué tipo de
arma pero tampoco se sabe cuál es el
paradero de los tripulantes así que la
gente sigue viviendo aquí está en contra
de ucraniano pero la situación sigue
siendo bastante inestable